so i got a really funny comment on  twitter that i think is worth sharing by  the way the handle on twitter is now at  legal eagle i got the main handle on  twitter i think that's great but  here's the comment i got if i've learned  anything from legal eagle  it's to not email anyone ever yeah so i  would never tell you to do  anything illegal but if you are going to  do something illegal  you should not put it in an email or in  the case of matt gates don't put it in  your venmo  history the bread and butter of  litigation these days is  culling over hundreds of thousands of  electronic documents whether it's emails  or files on the computer  and the documents don't tend to lie so  yeah if you're worried about committing  some sort of crime  don't put it in an email or i'll see you  in court